bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire et cette
semaine nous allons aborder la
classification ascendante hiérarchique
la classification ascendante
hiérarchique c'est vraiment dans la
continuité de la séance de la semaine
dernière donc je vous rappelle la
semaine dernière nous avions abordé
l'analyse factorielle et plus
spécifiquement l'analyse des
correspondances multiples qui est le cas
d' analyse factorielle pour des
variables de type catégorielles mais de
la même manière on peut faire une
analyse factorielle des correspondances
une analyse factorielle en composant
principal ou ac p lorsque l'on a des
variables quantitative au continu et
puis il est possible de faire
aujourd'hui d analyse factorielle mixte
avec des variables à la fois
quantitative et continue dans tous les
cas le principe de l'analyse factorielle
nous l'avions vu c'était de pouvoir
essayer d'avoir une réduction dimension
donc on va essayer de changer
l'idée c'est qu'on représente les
individus dans un espace à une dimension
humaine et notre nombre de variables et
donc du coup nous est de trouver un
autre référentiel pour représenter les
variables ou les premiers axes vous
concentrer le maximum de variance et
donc du coup ou la plus grande partie
des variations observable sont observés
via les deux premiers axes c'est ce
qu'on appelle le plan factoriel là le
principe de la classification ascendante
hiérarchique est dans la continuité de
la scène on va voir pourquoi mais elles
rendent dans le problème plus général
qui celui de la classification c'est à
dire nous avons un groupe d'observation
et on veut essayer de diviser l'ensemble
de nos observations en différents sous
groupes
donc c'est le principe de la
classification et il ya de nombreuses
techniques de classification comme comme
les cas moyenne par exemple et dans
l'une dans le principe d'une
classification
on cherche à avoir les groupes qui sont
le plus homogène en interne c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir des groupes de gens les
plus semblables possible
et les plus hétérogènes les uns par
rapport aux autres c'est à dire que les
individus deux groupes soit le plus
dissemblables possible donc on essaye de
regrouper des observations qui se
ressemblent et essayer de voir si on
peut du coup avoir une typologie qui en
émerge un peu comme dans une approche
qualitative on essaierait de faire
émerger des des profils types
alors avant d'attaquer la classification
à son entier rares chic qui est un des
types une des méthodes possibles en
termes de de classification il faut
qu'on aborde la notion de distance un
élément
essentiel dans une analyse de
classification ascendante hiérarchique
ça va être de trouver une manière de
mesurer une distance entre individus
l'idée c'est que deux individus qui
seraient complètement identique aurait
une distance entre deux héros que des
individus qui sont très différents est
une distance est élevé entre eux et que
des individus qui se ressemble un petit
peu mais qui sont pas tout à fait
identique est une distance entre eux
qu'ils soient plus faibles
autrement dit ce qu'on va appeler une
distance ici on c'est une sorte de
metric mathématiques qui va nous
permettre de mesurer le degré de
similitudes ou plutôt de dissimilitude
de nos similarités entre individus il
existe plusieurs types de distance je
vais vous projetez la page analyse air
pour vous présenter deux grands types de
distance qu'on va pouvoir utiliser dans
le cas présent donc ici vous avez sous
les yeux le site analyse r je vous en
parle régulièrement puisque les
webinaires s'appuie sur l'analyse air et
je vous propose dans la section analyse
et de rentrer sur le chapitre
classification ascendante et
hiérarchique et on va vous présenter au
tout début du coup la notion de distance
donc le principe de la classification
hiérarchique c'est qu'on va tout d'abord
calculé une matrice de distance donc on
va mesurer la distance entre chaque
individu par rapport à chacun des autres
individus de notre échantillon est à
partir de cette matrice de 10 ans
on va utiliser un algorithme de
regroupement pas à pas c'est à dire
qu'on va regrouper les individus qui se
ressemble de manière itérative jusqu'à
produire un arbre de classification
atteindre au g ça sera peut-être plus
clair quand on le verra tout à l'heure
comment ça ce ça se représente mais on
parle d'ordre hogra moutarde de
classification parce qu'on va regrouper
les individus 2 à 2 donc l'idée c'est
que deux individus qui se ressemblent
beaucoup en les regroupant ensemble puis
ensuite on va s'y trouver un autre petit
groupe où les gens se ressemblent et on
va du coup construire cet arbre ça
ressemble un peu à l'arbre du vivant que
vous pouvez peut-être connaître
quand vous regardez vous et pouvoir en
cours de biologie ou ça peut ressembler
aussi à des arbres de classification
phylogénétique on peut retrouver dans
d'autres domaines des sciences
donc cet arbre c'est s'attendre au g et
on dit que la classification est
ascendante
car on va partir des observations
individuel pour construire la
classification fur et à mesure et lé
hiérarchie car on va voir ça ça va
regrouper les individus étape par étape
et donc du coup on va recréer tout un
arbre ou dendre g
et puis lorsqu'on va découper cet arbre
et d'une certaine hauteur choisi on va
produire la partition disais donc là
cette notion de distance dont je vous
parlais elle va être utilisée pour
essayer d'identifier la ressemblance
entre observation et donc du coup là on
peut dire que la distance est l'opposé
de la ressemblance deux individus qui se
ressemblent auront entre eux une
distance très faible deux individus très
dissemblables auront distance élevé la
distance à correspond si un concept
mathématiques précis en mathématiques on
parle de distance lorsqu'une métriques
dispose de certaines particularités
notamment une distance est toujours
positive et l'idée c'est que si vous
avez trois individus à b et c
la distance entre l'individu à et
l'individu b elle est toujours inférieur
ou égal à la distance entre a et b entre
a et c et c -b
donc voilà ça renvoie à des choses plus
générale la distance on la connaît de
manière intuitive ce qu'on appelle la
distance euclidienne qui la distance
entre deux points dans le plan quand on
mesure la distance entre des points par
rapport à
à la dimension spatiale il y en a
d'autres qui vont exister on va pas
aborder toutes les distances
mathématiques impossible si ça vous
intéresse vous avez ici un lien vers un
support de cours qui vous présente les
distances de manière plus générale nous
on va s'intéresser à deux types de
distance qui vont fonctionner pour des
variables catégorielles nos variable
qualitative mais aussi qui marche avec
des variables continue d'ailleurs mais
qui vont permettre de mesurer une
similarité entre individus entre
observation on est dans le domaine des
sciences humaines et sociales et on va
avoir en fait de distance particulière
la distance du fis 2 qui est la distance
qui est utilisé de manière sous-jacente
dans l'analyse factorielle et c'est pour
ça qu'on va voir le lien entre analyse
factorielle et classification à son nom
qui est rare chic mais je vais déjà vous
introduire une autre distance qui est un
peu plus intuitive qui est moins connu
qui est la distance de gower qui la
distance de gower elle mesure en fait le
nombre de caractères semblables
sachez que cette notion de distance elle
reviendra lorsqu'on abordera
intérieurement la question de l'analyse
de séquences en sciences sociales donc
l'analyse de séquences qui est un champ
pour mesurer des trajectoires et bien en
fait dans la niche de séquences il ya de
la même manière un calcul de distance
entre trajectoire qui vont permettre de
faire des classifications et d'ailleurs
c'est un peu inspiré la distance des
classes des trajectoires sociales et
inspiré en fait un peu de ce qui se fait
en génétique mais on y reviendra dans le
chapitre sur l'analyse de séquences dans
un prochain webinaire tout
dès la distance de gower donc la
distance de coureurs elle est basée en
fait sur des travaux de gower tout
simplement qui en 1971 a proposé un
indice de similarités qui porte son nom
donc c'est un indice qui consiste à
mesurer dans quelle mesure deux
individus sont semblables et l' indice
de gower varie entre 0 et 1
si l'un dispose les deux individus sont
exotiques
à l'opposé s'il vaut zéro les deux
individus considérés non pas de points
communs et donc là à l'écran je vais
peut-être zoomer le texte donc on peut
noter sg d'accord lundi ce de similarité
de gower et bien la distance de gower
elle s'obtient assez facilement c'est
tout simplement la distance de gower des
gc 1 - sg donc la distance du coup elle
est nulle
si deux individus sont identiques et
elle vaut ainsi deux individus sont
totalement différentes
le principe de la distance de gower
alors vous avez ici la notation
mathématiques un peu formel ce qui est à
retenir c'est que on va regarder le nom
de caractère communs supposons deux
personnes un homme grand blond étudiants
urbain et une femme grande brune
étudiante rural ici nous avons retenu
cinq variables pour caractériser nos
individu ce qu'on va regarder c'est sur
ces cinq variables
combien y at-il de caractéristiques
communes on est bien entre l'individu 1
et l'individu 2 ils partagent en commun
deux caractéristiques
tous les deux sont grands et tous les
deux sont étudiants autrement dit sur
cinq variables ont cinq caractéristiques
ils ont deux en commun 'l'indice de
similarités c'est donc deux sur cinq le
nombre de caractéristiques communes sur
le nom total de caractéristiques
considérez donc ici c'est 04 40 % ils
ont 40% de caractéristiques en commun
et donc du coup la distance de gower
c'est tout simplement un moins 0,4 soit
06 60 % c'est le nombre de
caractéristiques différentes
vous voyez c'est assez intuitif si on a
des variables qui sont quantitative il
ya une extension qui existe dans la
définition la distance de 2 go where
pour en fait on regarde l'écart maximum
qui a entre le plus petit le plus grand
et puis on va voir à quel point ils sont
différents pas long ça complique un tout
petit peu mais ce qu'il faut retenir ici
c'est la philosophie un pur cover ce
qu'on retient c'est que on va regarder
simplement le nombre de caractéristiques
qui l'y a en commun cette distance de
gower elle est relativement peu utilisé
mais vous l'avez vu elle est assez
intuitive on regarde finalement le
nombre de caractéristiques en commun et
pour en créer une distance on regarde le
nombre de caractéristiques qui sont
différentes
ce qui est plus souvent utilisés dans le
domaine des sciences humaines et
sociales c'est la distance du fis de
cette distance
duffy de en fait il s'agit de la
distance qui est utilisé dans les
analyses des correspondances multiples
dans la cm et en fait c'est une variante
lot de la distance du chi 2 donc le chi
2 ça doit vous dire quelque chose c'est
la statistique qu'on utilise
lorsqu'on veut comparer deux variables
catégorielles qu'on fait un tableau
croisé ont fait un test du kit 2 est
donc derrière il ya une distance du chi
2 et dans les variantes on va avoir une
distance dite du fis 2 considérons que
nous avons qu question donc on accuse
variable et à chaque individu
et bien en fait on a eu un certain un
certain taux de réponses est en fait on
va regarder on va calculer une distance
mais on va tenir compte des probabilités
delà de la fréquence en fait de chacune
des modalités dans l'échantillon tels
que dit comme ça c'est pas très clair si
je vous montre à l'écran l'équation
mathématique je suppose que ça sera pas
forcément clair pour tout le monde donc
je vous propose illustrer tout ça par un
exemple concret encore une fois il n'y a
pas besoin de connaître les formules
mathématiques
ce qui est important c'est de retenir la
philosophie générale donc reprenons nos
deux individus nous avions un homme
grand blond étudiants urbain et nous
avions une femme grande brune étudiante
rural ce qui est important pour calculer
la distance du fis 2 c'est de connaître
la distribution de chacune de ces
modalités dans notre échantillon ici des
hommes représentent 52% les femmes 48 %
il ya 30 % de personnes qui sont classés
grands 45% moyens à 25 pour son petit
blond 15% chacun 45% brin 30% et c'est
la distance du fis de elle va regarder
les modalités non commune entre les deux
individus
donc là si je regarde caisse ou est ce
qu'ils diffèrent et bien hommes et
femmes blond et bruns et urbain et rural
donc
je regarde les mais les différences
entre les deux individus c'est sur le
sexe hommes et femmes sur la couleur de
cheveux blonds et bruns et sur le milieu
de résidence urbain et rural
en premier lieu on va regarder du coup
c'est si modalités là et on va regarder
la fréquence donc oms et 52% ou 0,52 on
va faire un sur 0 50 de femmes c'est 48%
on va faire un sur 0,48
puis on va faire un sur 0,15 et un sur 0
30 0 15 c blond 0,30 ses brins et enfin
1 / 0,81 et un sur 0,20 c'est donc
urbain et rural
donc on prend les modalités différentes
vous voyez que ici grand écho maindron
n'a pas tenu compte
étudiant comment n'a pas tenu compte on
additionne tout ça et on divise par le
nombre total de variable ici cinq et on
obtient une distance qui est de 4 05 ski
à retenir c'est que plus aura d'éléments
différents entre deux individus
plus on m'a dit 'ce youn et de choses
dans la parenthèse est donc plus la
distance sera grande
si l inverse on a deux personnes qui
sont totalement identique
eh bien on aurait eu rien dans la
parenthèse 0 / 5 ça m'a fait une
distance de 0,6 nos deux individus
n'avaient variés que par le sexe et que
tout le reste était identique à ce
moment là la distance entre ces deux
individus auraient été un sur 0 52 +1
sur 0,48
le tout divisé par cinq et si je vais
rapidement dans aer pour voir ce que ça
fait 1 / 0,42 peluche
c'est zéro
quand de pardon + 1 / 0 48
bien sûr j'ai fait une erreur et je
prends tout ça que je divise par cinq et
on obtient
8 donc s'il n'avait signé deux individus
avaient variés que sur le sexe on aurait
une distance de 0,8
donc ce qu'il faut retenir dans cette
distance duffy 2 c'est que la distance
du fis 2 elle dépend de la fréquence des
modalités dans l'échantillon si j'avais
eu un échantillon composé à 80% d'hommes
et 20% de femmes saurait modifier la
distance calculée entre les individus
alors que ma distance de gower elle est
totalement indépendante de la
répartition des modalités dans
l'échantillon
c'est en fait l'intérêt la distance de
gower la distance de gower elle va donc
du coup être assez intéressante
lorsqu'on s'intéresse plutôt aux effets
sans trop et qu'on est peu intéressés
par les individus marginaux parce que du
coup elle est peu sensible à des
modalités qui sont rares dans
l'échantillon la distance du fis deux
ailes au contraire va être très
sensibles à une modalité rare dans
l'échantillon supposons que nous aurions
99% d'urbain pour 1 % de ruraux à chaque
fois qu'il y aurait un rural dans
l'échantillon on aurait 1 / 0 k par 0,01
ça fait tout de suite sans et donc du
coup les modalités très rares vont avoir
un point important dans les distances ça
ça s'observe
quand on fait une analyse factorielle
l'analyse factorielle si vous avez une
modalité qui est très peu présente dans
l'échantillon les gens qui sont dans
cette dans ce groupe là sont tout de
suite apparaît très loin sur le plan
factoriel donc un impact énorme des
modalités rare quand on va faire on va
calculer de matrice de distance avec des
modalités qui sont rares on va avoir
tendance à avoir du coup les gens qui
sont dans ce groupe rat est à part des
tous les autres alors que si vous prenez
une distance de gower comme on a vu
qu'on regarde juste un taux de
caractéristiques communes ou pas commune
et que la distribution marginale des
modalités ne compte pas il y aura
finalement peu d'impact sur l'analyse ce
qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'il ya quelque chose de
similaire en tout cas entre les deux
autres distances de gower et distant
duffy 2 on cherche à mesurer à quel
point deux individus sont semblables non
ce qui change fondamentalement entre les
deux c'est que dans gower c'est assez
intuitif dans la distance de gower on va
tout simplement on va tout simplement
regarder les modalités en commun dans la
distance du fid 2 on regarde aussi la
distribution marginal de chacune des
variables qui est plaisant
retenez aussi un la distance du fis 2
elle est adaptée au cas spécifique des
variables catégorielles et quand on a
uniquement des bars et catégorielles ce
qui correspond à ce qu'on appelle la cm
on va voir que avec à 2,4 avec traminer
on peut faire des analyses mixte et en
fait on a une extension du système donc
la philosophie globale existe aussi
quand on a des variables qui sont
purement continue on fait une assez paix
on peut calculer une distance c'est plus
la distance de fille de mais on est sur
un peu le même idée on va retrouver les
personnes les plus proches et les
personnes et plus distantes et quand on
fait des analyses mix du coup il ya une
combinaison qui elle aussi qui s'adapte
quant à gower comme je vous l'aï dit
plus près précédemment elle est adaptée
il ya une extension de gower qui tient
compte des variables qui sont continue
alors
ce que je vous prends
c'est sur terre studio et nous allons
dans un premier temps regarder les
données de l'exemple qui va nous servir
pour aujourd'hui je charge un studio
vous le savez un l'habitude maintenant
depuis toutes nos sessions je vais faire
un nouveau projet qui va ce jeu les
stocker mon script d'aujourd'hui là j'ai
des projets séparés pour chacune des
sessions mais quand vous êtes sur un
même projet d' analyse on n'a pas
forcément besoin aujourd'hui c'est donc
notre webinaire 12 si je ne me trompe
pas je vais le mettre dans mes documents
tout simplement document il est là et on
va créer le projet
je vais tout
nouveau script donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on
va voir si la classification ascendante
l'hiérarchie qu ou ch
première chose je vais sauvegarder mon
script donc soit le petit bouton
sauvegarder ici soit la combinaison de
touches contrôle s est donc aujourd'hui
ça va être le script sur la ch premier
ap on va charger les données
donc pour rester dans la suite de ce
qu'on a fait la semaine dernière on va
repartir de la scène que nous avions vu
la semaine dernière donc on va charger
cautionneur et charges
evs et 2003 pareil
à prendre toujours mêmes habitudes donc
je vais charger le taille diverse pour
pouvoir préparer rapidement mes données
et du coup quelques éléments
particuliers faut que je recrée quelques
variables
on va déjà créé une variable groupes
d'âge alors pour réviser je vais vous
montrer comment est ce qu'on le fait
avec le hadith de quest ix honneur donc
pour rappel vous avez le petit add in an
où je vais chercher les à digne de
questionnaires et là je veux prendre la
variable âge qui ne va rien continue
pour en faire une variable de catégorie
donc on va avoir recours à numérique
dividing je suis dans hdv 2003
je veux recoder âge je vais faire une
nouvelle variable qui s'appelle groupe h
découpage en classe là c'est moi qui
vais directement donné les endroits où
je veux couper je vais faire une enquête
je vais découper avant 25 ans pour les
jeunes 45 ans pour voir 25 44 ans un
groupe on va dire de deux personnes qui
sont au début de la vie active qui après
je vais couper à 65 ans pour avoir avant
la retraite après la retraite
je rajoute toujours les valeurs extrêmes
si nécessaire inclut la valeur extrême
ici je regarde mon résultat découpage en
classe il ya des résultats et je regarde
le tableau que j'obtiens donc j'ai des
18 25 25 45 45 65 65 97 g pas de valeur
mais comme ce que j'ai bien pris les
valeurs extrêmes et je vais de 18
jusqu'à 25
vous voyez ces 18 inclus jusqu'à 25
exclut donc roi est égale files par
défaut c'est ce qui me fallait c'est de
ce dont j'ai besoin
je clique sur donne et le code ici est
directement ajouté dans mon script
de la même manière
r on va prendre le niveau d'études on va
regrouper pour en faire une variable un
peu plus un peu plus courte donc la g
prend l'hiver ce riz coding hdv 2003
c'est la variable nive études je vais en
faire une nouvelle variable que je vais
appeler tout simplement et hu dont je
clique sur codage et donc ce qu'on va
faire on va d'abord coder les premières
modalités ensemble pour faire un niveau
primaire puis un niveau secondaire j'ai
recoupé
technique et professionnel et je vais
rendre le niveau supérieur par ailleurs
la si je fais mon analyse tel quel les
les individus si vous souvenez il ya pas
mal de gens ainsi je fais que des
résultats vous voyez que j'ai quand même
pas mal de valeurs manquantes 112
valeurs manquantes et donc du coup je
vais en faire une modalité en soi donc
je vais faire une maudite et non
documentés ce qui veut dire que j'ai un
niveau d'étude qui n'est pas documenté
mais là je la transforme en modalité
proprement dite pour l'analyse et donc
ce qu'il va rajouter un ff7 est
explicite et n'a à mon code je clique
sur donne le code et fait donc là je
reviens pas plus en détail si vous vous
souvenez tous nous l'avons abordée déjà
dans des versions précédentes
maintenant de l'esa je vais faire donc
je rêve
écoutant tout mon code depuis le début
aussi je veux le faire directement je
peux cliquer sur source
d'ailleurs quand vous cliquez sur source
ouvert et qui m'a enregistre
automatiquement la version actuelle de
mon code et là je vais faire la cm donc
là pour ça j'avais déjà choisir un
sous-ensemble de variables je vais
partir pardon je veux faire un objet des
deux qui va contenir
hdv 2003 et je l'utilisé select pour
retenir que les variables d'intérêt qui
sont du coup le groupe d'âge
j'ai appelé aux pages le sec
le niveau d'études et puis on avait
utilisé la semaine dernière pêche chasse
cinéma cuisine bricole
âge sport et lectures et bd
donc on se
vient le sélect de deep la guerre et
j'obtiens un objet d 2 1 qui contient
que les variables en question et puis
pour faire la cm tout simplement je vais
appeler la fonction alors j'ai oublié il
faut que je charge ade 4 qui va être
nécessaire pour faire l'analyse
l'acm et je vais faire un objet que je
vais appeler juste assez m
du 10 as et m je lui passe mon jeu de
données qui des deux est pour pas avoir
la partie interactive qui va me donner
le nombre d'actes que je veux gagner que
je veux garder je vous voyez ici qu'on a
la petite syntaxe qui apparaît l'option
scan nf va être égal à face et je vais
indiquer qu'on va garder tout simplement
si je fais nf égal f c'est à dire un
fini donc infini pour rappel un c'est le
chiffre images c'est la lettre i
majuscule ed f en minuscule ça va garder
du coup tous les axes de l'analyse à
l'intérieur donc là ce que nous avons
fallait c'est tout simplement de refaire
l'analyse factorielle de la semaine
dernière
la proche
tapez c'est donc tout simplement le
calcul de la matrice des distances quand
je dis matrisez distance et qu'en fait
on va avoir un grand rectangle
en l'occurrence nous avons ici pour
rappel si je fais des deux n va aux 2000
individus et donc on va calculer la
distance de tous les individus à tous
les autres et donc on va faire ce qu'on
appelle une matrice qui va être ici en
l'occurrence un grand carré de 2000
lignes et 2000 colonnes avec du coup
dans chacune des cases du carré la
distance de chaque individu à tous les
autres pour calculer la matrice de
distance
happart
c'est m donc là nous avons fait la sem
avec à des quatre on verra un peu plus
tard comme on peut faire la même chose
avec le paquet de facto myners et si la
cm a été fait avec à 2,4 nous avons une
fonction qui s'appelle 10 points du 10
qui permet d'obtenir cette matrice de
distance donc je vais faire une maîtrise
de distance que je l'appelais md et
j'appelle la fonction d'ist point du dit
et je lui passe mon acr ça mais quelques
donc quelques secondes à être calculée
et là vous avez du coup un gros objet 1
md en fait il ya beaucoup d'éléments
mais techniquement vous avez en fait un
tableau de 2000 ligne sur 2000 et fait
alors un tableau 10 disent tu qu'une
matrice de distance 1 mais grosso modo
ça vous indique la distance de chaque
individu avec chaque chacun des deux
mille individus et sa distance avec
chacun dès 1999 et autres individus ça
c'est si l'on veut faire une matrice de
distance avec la cm et si je veux le
faire avec la distance de gower
on va voir
ce fait tout aussi facilement et tout
aussi rapidement pour ça on a besoin de
passer par la fonction d easy du package
cluster je vais donc chargé en mémoire
le package kloster et donc je vais faire
une un deuxième document j'ai appelé md
gower pour consommer ne s'est pas la
même j'appelle la fonction daisy alors
le calcul la matrice de la distance de
gower ne se fait pas à partir d'une
assez m il se fait directement à partir
d'un jeu de données là j'ai déjà fait un
jeu de données qui ne contient que mes
colocs d'intérêt qui ce qui est des deux
donc je vais passer des deux voiliers je
passe tout un tableau mais qui n'a que
les colonnes d'intérêt pour l'analyse et
je vais indiquer métriques égale gower 1
pour indiquer le type de distance à
calculer alors peut-être ici une petite
erreur md gower et voyez le calcul s'est
fait très rapidement et j'obtiens une
matrice de distance
md gower avec le calcul et dont vous
voyez ça se fait très rapidement ce
calcul des distances
on va du coup passé à l' approche
tap qui est le cas
du centre g donc maintenant
une matrice de distance on va essayer de
repérer la ddt dans les dix les
individus qui se ressemblent le plus et
de les regrouper à chaque fois en fait
on prend tous ceux qui se ressemblent
plus on va rire qu'on paie au fur et à
mesure pour recalculer à un arbre ou
dans trop gras mais pour ça du coup on a
besoin d'une méthode d'agrégation alors
il faut savoir que sur ce point là là
aussi ça vous intéresse il peut y avoir
beaucoup de lecture car il ya de
nombreux solution différente qui
existent tels que le seuil minimum la
distance maximum la moyenne noire
en fait il ya beaucoup de manières à
partir d'une matrice de distance de
calculer à un arbre d'agrégation il faut
savoir que chacune de ces méthodes à
produire un tendre au g différents alors
je vais pas détailler ici les
différentes techniques sachez que si ça
vous intéresse
normalement vous devriez vous pouvez
consulter le cours de carpentier qui est
citée sur un analyseur dans lequel on va
les expliciter si c'est un sujet qui ne
vous intéressent pas en particulier
retenu une chose
la méthode la plus courante et la plus
classique consiste à utiliser la méthode
dite de ward de manière simplifiée et je
dis bien de manière simplifiée donc je
vais mettre des guillemets cette méthode
cherche à minimiser l'inertie intra
classe et à maximiser l'inertie
interclasses afin d'obtenir les classes
et plus homogène possible en interne et
les plus hétérogènes possibles entre
elles
donc je reprends la phrase on cherche à
minimiser l'inertie un tract on cherche
à faire en sorte qu'ils aient le moins
de variations à l'intérieur d'une classe
donc à l'intérieur les individus soient
le plus homogène possible se ressemblent
plus est
à maximiser l'inertie inter-caisses
devons faire en sorte qu'il ya un
maximum de variance qui soit entre les
classes alors ça c'est la manière donc
en fait très souvent vous pourrez lire
que cette méthode qui vise à minimiser
la variance au sein des classes alors
les spécialistes des statistiques vous
diront que c'est pas exactement vrai et
au sens strict
ward vise l'augmentation minimum de la
somme des carrés alors là on arrive sur
des débats un peu technique c'est vous
intéresse il ya des quelques références
sur le chapitre analyseur ce qui est à
retenir pour nous c'est que il ya
plusieurs techniques d'agrégation qui
existent pour construire un arbre
d'agrégation et dans les faits vous
pouvez avoir deux trois stratégies soit
vous vous y connaissez très bien en
stats c'est vous avez une raison
particulière de choisi un type de
méthode d'agrégation plutôt qu'une autre
parce que vous avez les éléments
mathématiques pour prenez cette méthode
là soit vous avez une autre approche qui
consiste à dire je vais utiliser
plusieurs techniques pour voir laquelle
me donne la classification qui fait le
plus en ce soit où vous savez pas trop
par quel bout prendre ça et dans ce cas
la fête comme la majorité des gens quand
utiliser ce qui est le plus courant dans
le domaine des sciences humaines et
sociales pour le cas d'une
classification hiérarchique ascendante
pour créer une typologie à partir de
variables sociales qui consiste à
utiliser la méthode de ward plus précis
aimant il faut savoir que ce qui est
utilisé ce n'est pas tant la méthode de
ward que la méthode de ward appliquée au
carré les distances c'est un petit peu
plus subtil mais on va voir comment ce
calcul cet arbre et vous allez voir
c'est assez simple donc le calcul du
d'andrew g
je vais à
ça arbres je vais pas être très se fait
avec la fonction de base deux ex h clust
je lui passe une matrice de distance on
va ici lui passer la matrice md et on
lui dit la méthode à utiliser
est ce qu'on va utiliser ici c'est la
méthode dite ward points des deux et ça
y est mon
mais calculer alors je vous montre à
quoi ça ressemble et après je vous
explique cet enjeu de méthode pour le
calcul gfr déjà aux plus âgés faire
pelote deux arbres pour faire un
graphique de mon arbre alors c'est
parfois pas toujours facile à lire je
vais faire je la baisse et khalfa pour
cacher les étiquettes qui sont les
numéros d'observation donc ce que vous
voyez là c'est la manière dont les dons
se regroupe les différentes modalités au
fur et à mesure alors donc là vous avez
il essaie que tout tombe à chaque petit
point correspond d'observation est donc
là vous êtes à observation qui se
ressent qu'on va regrouper ensemble et
puis ensuite voyez on a des dd paquet
qu'on va regrouper ensuite encore
ensemble deux par deux et donc vous avez
ici différentes manières de regrouper
les observations si vous regardez l'aide
de hache clust
vous verrez que vous avez un paramètre
méthode avec plusieurs avec plusieurs
termes possible entre confl it war point
des world points des deux singles
complète average msp equity mais johnson
floride
donc vous avez en dessous les détails
mathématiques de ces différentes
méthodes
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ça
change égèrement l'arbre que l'on
obtient si je faisais pelote 2h clust
2ème des aigles aux méthodes légales
comme clé y travaillent
pas du tout le même arbre si je le fais
avec ward point des jeux
un autre arbre là c'est sans avoir pris
la distance au carré si je prends la
distance car et c'est celle que là on a
favorisé j'obtiens ce regroupement là
alors parfois la question peut se poser
s'il vaut mieux utiliser la matrice
distances simples la matrice des
distances au carré quand on utilise
world fact oman facto myners par exemple
par défaut utilise toujours la distance
au carré donc là il ya il peut y avoir
des débats chez des spécialistes
si vous vous savez pas trop utiliser
plutôt la distance au carré mais voyez
on a plusieurs manières de regrouper on
n'obtient pas tout à fait le même arbre
ce que je veux surtout vous montrer
c'est si vous avez des doutes par défaut
partait sur la distance ward au carré et
si le résultat vous avez à la fin vous
convient pas trop essayé vont selon de
voir si vous auriez un résultat plus
intéressant avec tammy la méthode ward
simple je vous montre malgré tout un
autre arbre qu'on peut avoir c'est si on
était parti de la matrice de distance de
gower pour vous nous on va voir tout du
long j'ai vous faire les deux et on
verra du coup en quoi on obtient quelque
chose d'un peu différent donc là je
l'appelais arbres gower et si je fais
plein de arbres gower envoyée
a complètement une autre manière de
regrouper et on voit des recoupements à
différents endroits alors
rapidement les commentaires une des
questions qui est posée ici c'est la
classification fondée sur la distance de
gower ne repose donc pas sur une analyse
factorielle préalable tout à fait donc
je vous rappelle ce que je vous
présentais au début soit on part d'une
analyse factorielle des correspondances
cette analyse factorielle repose sur la
distance du fis de la distance du fils
de est une distance qui est un quine qui
tient compte des distributions marginal
de chacune des variables catégorielles
et donc on part d'une assez m
on applique d'ist dudit et on obtient du
coup ses distances du fis 2 si vous avez
des variables et catégorielles et
continue vous auriez en fait ici utilisé
du 10 mx plutôt que tu dis est cm donc
ça aurait été une analyse des
correspondances mixte sans rentrer dans
les détails mathématiques que je vous
avoue je ne connais pas mais la
philosophie reste la même et vous
obtenez une distance qui est une sorte
d'extension à 10 ans du fils de qui sait
prendre en compte dans la catégorie yale
et on aurait eu le même effet l'autre
approche c'est celle que je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure c'est la
distance de gower growers c'est une
distance qui est beaucoup plus intuitive
on regarde le nombre de caractères en
commun qu'ont les individus et donc la
distance et le nombre de caractères qui
ne sont pas partagées par un individu si
on regarde huit variables et que deux
individus de partage que deux caractères
en commun du coup ils ont six caractères
de différents leurs distances ces six
sur huit
tout simplement et du coup gower ne
dépend pas de la distribution marginal
puisque on regarde juste qu'est ce qui
est pareil qu'est-ce qui est pas pareil
et ça ne repose donc pas sur une analyse
factorielle préalable saison juste une
autre approche pour calculer la distance
donc c'est en un mot qui va y avoir une
variation par contre une fois qu'on a
notre matrice distance toute la suite de
l'analyse se fait de manière totalement
identique
et quand on fera l'analyse le chapitre
sur l'analyse de séquences on verra
qu'on a une manière particulière de
calculer les distances entre séquences
mais tout le reste une fois qu'on a
c'est de matrice de distance se fait de
la même manière on a donc recours à la
fonction achat clust
pour calculer notre arbre et donc la
question qui se pose maintenant c'est
comment est-ce qu'on découpe tout ça
donc je vous représente je vous remets
première manière de représenter
graphiquement un arbre c'est la fonction
de base de r pelote j'ai pas la plus
esthétique mais ça fait le travail donc
pelote deux arbres
et puis vous avez cette option là belz
égale fall ce qui permet de retirer les
étiquettes ouvriers en bas qui superpose
en fait c'est le nom d observation en
l'occurrence et leurs 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
comme on en a deux mille c'est pas du
tout lisible et donc vous
andrew g et donc on va se poser la
question de couper le dans programme
ce qui est important
retenir c'est que veut dire se tendre au
g d'accord donc l'idée c'est qu'on a
regroupé des individus qui se
ressemblent entre eux et vous voyez ça
fait à chaque fois des petits groupes
qui après on va regrouper des petits
groupes en sont les puis on regroupe
tout court ce petit groupe ensemble et
on regroupe encore ces petits groupes
l'ensemble jusqu'à ce que l'on monte la
hauteur dans le d'andrew g
elle indique où est-ce que se font les
coupes où se font les regroupements donc
plus il ya une hauteur élevée à
l'endroit d'un regroupement
ça ça me lie à une hauteur assez
différente on voit bien que ces
individus là sont différents de ces
individus ici et donc on peut envisager
de découper à différents endroits
notre programme alors pour repérer où
couper un on a plusieurs manières de
faire on peut déjà on l'a vu faire le
graphique classique avec les fonctions
de base dans air
donc je
r pelote de mon arbre et puis voir
qu'est ce qui se passe si j'ai découpé
en plusieurs en plusieurs classes et
vous avez du coup pour le voir à l'écran
on peut faire par exemple rect point h
clust arbres à 2 donc là le principe et
après je vais mettre une couleur par
exemple dire border égal réd
donc si je fais ça là on est on est plus
dans la logique ggp lot elle en est sûre
du graphique air assez classique ça va
redessiner comment le don programme
serait découpé si on le découper en deux
classes si on découpe en deux
classements par de tout temps au hangar
au premier endroit où ça se divise en
deux et donc on obtient nos deux groupes
je pourrais regarder ce qui se passe si
je le découpe est enceinte
et là je vais faire
leur égal blue sea jeudi
et en cinq classes en fait on descend en
partant du online pour choisir un
endroit où on fait la découpe et on voit
où est-ce que se ferait cette découpe on
voit ici qu'on aurait une classe petit
un peu isolé et là on aurait une très
grande classe sur la droite et une
classe de ce1 peu moyenne sur la gauche
ça c'est une première manière de
visualiser si on fait le graphique assez
classique du d'entre aux g et ensuite on
applique règles taxe clust
il ya quelques package qui existent pour
avoir un peu plus d'options sur les
représentations du don programme je vais
vous en présenter quelques-unes
vous avez notamment la librairie d'hand
extend et avec elle je peux lui passait
alors d'une part elle permet par exemple
d'appliquer de passer un d'andrew g à gg
pelote je peux faire maintenant ggp lot
alors si je charge aussi je peux faire
ggp lot de mon arbre 1 et donc il n'a
pas voulu
il faut que je
verte' cela en objet de dexter on va
faire une excuse un jeu je me trompe ce
qui m'intéresse moi c'est sur la
fonction qu leur branche
il ya une fonction de détection qui
s'appelle kohler branche je lui passe un
arbre je lui dis le nombre de classes
voyons voir ce qu'est ce qui se passe si
je découpe en cinq classes donc à ecalle
5 et tout ça je peux le passé à gg
pelote
alors ça mais
instant à ce calcul est un petit peu
lourd mais vous allez voir l' avantage
et on
1 1 une autre représentation graphique
du drot g c'est le même qu'on avait tout
juste avant un peu plus propre
ici du coup on a c'est on voit bien
directement les les différentes branches
et j'aurais pu rajouter danger plus est
ici un label segal files pour supprimer
les étiquettes en bas d'un texte et je
réponds tout à la question parce qu'elle
elle met souvent posée lorsque lorsque
je présente c'est que certains
voudraient par exemple inverser l'ordre
c'est-à-dire que le premier groupe
complètement rouge soit totalement à
droite et dans dexter et c'est en fait
le même arbre d'ailleurs hendrix ted
donne des outils qui permettent de
pivoter là pour leur présenter d'une
autre manière
si vous vous souvenez nous avions vu la
semaine dernière la fonction le package
facto ex train qui fournit un service ou
de fonction graphique pour l'analyse
factorielle et si une des fonctions
fournis par facto extra c'est une
fonction de représentation d'un temps
programme notamment avec f vise dnd donc
je lui passe mon arbre je peux indiquer
si je veux montrer un découpage en ca
internet de catégorie je peux lui passer
une valeur donc à égal 5 par exemple et
je lui passais tout de suite show la
baisse égale phalsbourg pas mettre les
étiquettes en bas puisque c'est pas
lisible de toute façon avec 2000
observations et éventuellement rect égal
tout pour afficher des rectangles autour
des catégories
on va
instant que ça se calcule c'est des gros
objets c'est pour ça que c'est parfois
long a représenté graphiquement
c'est toujours
live en fait l'ordinateur récupère le
flux et vous l'envoyez du coup ça va
plus lentement mais on devrait avoir le
graphique sous peu
voilà donc le voilà vous voyez c'est
pareil en est sur le même principe une
colorisation des différentes branches
vous pouvez personnaliser la palette de
couleurs utilisées pour la colorisation
des branches il suffit de regarder
l'aide de la fonction elvis dandin pour
avoir un peu plus de détails
vous voyez qu'on a quelques fonctions
comme ça qui nous permettent d'avoir une
une visitation assez rapide ou couper le
landreau g la question qui se pose c'est
devrait-on utiliser un découpage en deux
classes en trois classes en cas de casse
en cinq classes en six classes en lutte
l'a senti classe et ça c'est un c'est un
débat qui n'est qui est pas toujours
simple alors on a plusieurs outils à
notre disposition mais déjà ce qui est
important de savoir c'est aussi à quoi
vous voulez quel est le but de la
classification vous faites est en
fonction de l'analyse vous pouvez
choisir d'avoir des classes qu'ils
soient plus ou moins fines plus ou moins
et vous pouvez avoir besoin d'avoir
peut-être vous avez besoin en fait de
simplifier votre analyse
et de résumer votre échantillon donc
vous voulez plutôt avoir un nombre de
classes restreint trois ou quatre
classes au maximum ou au contraire vous
auriez besoin d'avoir un grand nombre de
classes parce que vous les gardez plein
de détails dans l'analyse mais du coup
ce qui vient aussi complexifier la
partie interprétative ou quelqu'un vous
pourriez vouloir avoir autour d'une
dizaine d'une douzaine de classes donc
déjà il ya un premier élément à vous
poser c'est combien de classes seraient
utiles pour vous en fonction de
l'analyse que vous voulez faire une
autre manière
un autre élément à considérer c'est de
regarder les sauts d'inertie alors je
vais vous représentez les alors on peut
calculer les sauts d'inertie donc on va
partir de notre arbre donc
gfr
les inerties et je vais l'idée c'est de
trier la hauteur des différentes
branches de l'arbre
donc ça peut se faire avec sorte arbres
dollars waits 10 kw easing légal trou là
on va déjà obtenir un grosso modo un peu
la liste des auteurs des branches c'est
en fait ce point là puisque pour l'appui
ce point là puis ce point là puis ce
point là puis ce point là puis ce point
ici puis ce point là donc on voit que
j'obtiens enfin les différentes hauteurs
et on va regarder ça si je fais pelote g
que je m'intéresse uniquement première
valeur donc pelote inertie si je vous
montre les 20 premières et je faire type
égale est donc là on est en syntaxe
classique de r pas besoin de tout
retenir mais on voit comment se font les
sauts ce qui se passe et que parfois il
ya clairement on voit un gros un gros
écart
alors ici c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
aidé quand on regarde le graphique un
jour mais le nôtre graphique de notre
arbre c'est vrai que il ya plein de
petits sauts étape par étape il n'y a
pas de grandes catégories bien séparées
qui émergent
si je regarde l'arbre qu'on avait fait
avec govou heures
3 il ya bien trois quatre grands groupes
qui émerge un ici un l'a1 là et un ici
donc là on est sûr avec bauer donc à
présent puisque ça dépend vraiment des
données on voit plutôt quand même un peu
quatre groupes clairement émergé et si
je faisais l'inertie avec bauer et que
je vous fais le
clic voyez là
une rupture il ya grand saut grand saut
puis là quelques petits sauts ce qu'est
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on n'a
pas intérêt à couper un arbre au milieu
d'un petit saut d'accord donc il va dire
que je prend 4,4 groupe ne ferait pas
sens parce que si je reviens à mon
graphique
attendez on reprend la c12 je me trompe
pas je trouve toujours d'un cran pas sur
le nombre de modalités
la ccit on a cinq modalités on descend
ici 4 3
si je reviens sur l'arbre voilà si je
coupe
2 ça me fait un groupe là un groupe ici
si je coupe en 3 je vais couper à ce
niveau là mais si je coupe en quatre
jeux coupe juste à ce niveau là je vous
montre le le graphique si on faisait en
quatre on va faire
si si je faisais gower et que je coupais
bauer en 4 ce sera peut-être plus
parlant avec la colorisation
encore une fois je
un petit peu de patience c'est toujours
un petit peu long vous voyez si je coupe
en quatre
on va déjà coupé en deux puis on va
couper on va prendre ces deux branches
là puis cette branche là va être coupée
en deux sauf que si vous voyez à peu
près la même hauteur j'ai aussi cette
branche là qui se situe à la même
hauteur donc couper en 4 ferait pas sens
j'ai intérêt soit découpée en 5 soit de
se dire ça c'est au même cran je coupe
au dessus l'idée en général c'est qu'on
coupe contient un grand saut on coupe à
l'endroit il ya un grand sauver son
couple juste au dessus du saut soit en
coupe en dessous donc là je pourrai
coupée en trois catégories
ou plutôt coupé en cinq catégories mais
découpé en quatre ça fait pas forcément
sens et éventuellement même coupé en six
catégories parce que voyez là ça c'est
pas très loin de ce point là encore une
fois c'est tout va dépendre de qu'est-ce
qu'on veut récupérer là je dirais trois
catégories ça peut être pas mal
5 1 mais ces deux donc c'est de regarder
où on va se faire on va voir quelque
chose qui est plus marqué c'est sûr là
où il ya des grands shows donc ici ça
peut faire sens de couper la séquence
est coupé du coup en trois catégories ou
5 j'irais plutôt 6 ici donc on aurait
plutôt intérêt à couper en 6 ou en trois
catégories
là encore une fois je vous donne les
indications qui sont purement ici basé
sur quelque chose de visuel
certains auteurs ont voulu essayer de
trouver des indicateurs un peu plus
précis et par exemple quand vous
utilisez le package facto mein herr lui
à faire une suggestion de coupure qui
est basé sur un critère qu'ils appellent
le plus grand saut d'inertie relatif
c'est à dire qu'on regarde la taille du
saut mais par rapport à la hauteur de
départ alors si vous êtes intéressé par
ce cet indicateur là il se trouve que
j'avais créé il ya longtemps que j'en
avais besoin une petite fonction qui
s'appelle baisse 4 free qui vous permet
de vous le calculé à partir d'un arbre
sauf que c'est une fonction qui est du
coup mise dans ce que j'appelle jl
utilise alors j elle utilise
c'est un package un peu fourre tout que
je développe au gym et un peu des trucs
et astuces que je récupère à droite à
gauche et du coup comme c'est quelque
chose d'un peu disparate ou parfois je
vais y mettre une fonction qui va
disparaître
quand j'aurai une version meyer qui va
aller dans un package stable du coup j
ai l'utilisent n'est pas disponible sur
qui surprend vous pouvez pas l'installer
directement par la fonction package ici
j'ai lu tisser disponible uniquement sur
sur sur github
et donc ça peut s'installer avec le
package jeff schultz et la fonction un
stargate aube l'art marange
jl utilise quelques précisions sous
windows vous aurez peut-être besoin
d'installer aussi ce qu'on appelle r
tous vous avez le lien ici pour
télécharger r truth qui sont des
fonctions supplémentaires pour compiler
des package à partir du code source
quand vous installez un paquet je puis
get up vous avez plutôt intérêt à avoir
mis à jour tous vos autres paquets de la
ce moment-là et vérifier s'il ya des
éléments requis après peut-être que vous
avez pas envie d'installer j'ai lu thi
luu vous avez des primes pour
l'installer vous voulez que la fonction
baisse club choi il est possible de
télécharger d'installer que cette
fonction avec cette ligne de code
ici qui vous est donnée là donc je peux
copier ça dans le presse-papier la
coller ici dans mon script donc gros
modo en fait ça va télécharger un
fichier est requis et du coup sur github
dans le package il utilise donc là vous
avez le lien la fonction url pour dire
que c'est un lien web et ensuite on
l'appelle à source
si je fais ça ça va télécharger le
fichier l'exécuter et normalement
maintenant vous avez dans votre
environnement une fonction qui s'appelle
bes cap tri et la fonction elle est
assez simple et peut fonctionner par
elle même donc comment fonctionne bes
cap choi le principe c'est que je vais
lui passer un arbre donc si j'aurais sur
gower
alors
par défaut il va me donner un résultat
oui j'ai passé la commande il me renvoie
3 donc il me dit selon lui et selon ce
critère là le meilleur endroit où couper
c'est en trois mais si je veux voir les
choses plus visuel je peux demander à
faire un graphique donc ce qui fait
c'est que il donc ça calcule ce fameux
critères un perte relative d'inertie et
le l'intérêt ça serait de couper là où
ce critère est le plus bas donc ici si
on s'intéresse entre 3 et 20 la
meilleure coupure serait en trois et
ensuite le deuxième meilleur andro coupé
ça serait en cinq classes selon ce
critère
et c'est qu'un critère parmi d'autres si
je refais la même chose sur l'arbre
calculées à partir de l'acm des
résultats sont un peu différent et on
nous dirait que le mieux serait de
couper en trois ou six noms après en
quatre en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
tout est un peu trop continue pour pour
que ce critère donne vraiment quelque
chose de plus poussé certains d'entre
vous si ça les intéresse
il ya plein d'autres indicateurs qui ont
été créés pour savoir pour mesurer la
qualité d'une partition c'est à dire ce
qu'il vaut mieux couper en trois ans 4
et donc ça chaque chacune de ça ça donne
une partition et si certains sont
intéressés il faut les regarder du côté
du package british plaster parmi
d'autres extensions qui existe et whitey
cluster en fête permet de calculer
différents indicateurs
avec la fonction ask last witch donc
dans ce cas là on fait à ce club ce
point on lui passe un arbre donc un an
dro g et il a besoin aussi la matrice de
distance correspondante
si on est
tout ça ça va renvoyer en fait tout un
tas d'indicateurs de qualité si on coupe
en deux en trois ans 4 alors je vais pas
vous les expliquer tous en détail il
faudrait regarder la documentation de
manière plus générale mais on peut aussi
faire de tout ça un graphique ce qui
permet de je vous avoue je n'arrive
jamais à me souvenir lesquels doivent
son mieux quand on les baisse ou quand
on les monte mais quand on voit le
graphique on voit à peu près vous voyez
là où il ya pas mal de changements sur
pas mal l'indicateur celui-ci il est
maximisée en trois ceux là sont
minimisés entre on se dit bien à 3 et
peut-être quelque chose de pas mal et
après ce jeu quand j'ai besoin d'aller
voir un peu plus loin on va aller
regarder du côté des de la documentation
de white leicester pour retrouver le
manuel qui existe d'ailleurs en français
vous avez le lien de whitey cluster est
développé par une équipe suisse c'est la
même équipe qui développe en fait
traminer qui est le package de l'analyse
de séquences ils intéressés que la
documentation est à la fois disponible
en anglais et en français
et là vous avez un manuel détaillé qui
présentent chacun de ces indicateurs est
le sens qu'il a et comme on peut
l'interpréter
l'idée générale c'est que sur certains
indicateurs comme la sw c'est de
regarder ce qu'on appelle une silhouette
l'idée est un c'est de regarder quand je
prends une classe c'est quoi la forme du
centre de classe et est ce que les gens
qui sont dedans ressemble à la personne
qui au milieu ça c'est l'idée générale
en tout cas il n'y a pas de de recettes
miracles pour savoir où couper son arbre
là je vous ai montré baisse coach rick
une des approches possibles à vous avez
une différents série d'indicateurs qui
vous dise
a priori se passe quelque chose à 3 et
puis l'autre élément c'est de regarder
la tête de l'arbre et de se dire qu'est
ce qui fait sens encore une fois on va y
revenir après quand on va tester la
classification les classifications
automatiques sont jamais des solutions
magiques et on va voir après on va
essayer de voir ce que deux
classifications et c'est surtout
l'analyse de s que notre classification
va avoir du sens du point de vue
sociologique pour voir si on veut la
retenir
je vous montre le même résultat
lorsqu'on prend le calcification à
partir de gower et là sur go
or c'est un petit peu moins clair il ya
une partie autour de 5 une partie autour
de trois ouvriers
il ya un peu deux endroits il se passe
des choses 5 ou 3 et si je regarde à
nouveau mon arbre un clairement
on prend ces trois groupes là soit on en
prend ça je vous dirai ça dépend aussi
du niveau des taxes on a besoin pour la
suite de l'analyse
dans certains cas on va faire une
classification parce que on a plein de
variables de départ et on veut avoir
juste trois profils dans d'autres cas on
veut avoir des profils très différents
donc voilà tout dépend aussi de si vous
êtes plutôt une recherche d'avoir un
petit peu moins ou un peu plus de deux
classes retenez qu'on peut découper à
différents niveaux suivants ce suivant
ce qui se passe l'autre élément là on
voit émerger quelque chose autour de
trois ou cinq classes 1 suivant les deux
approches c'est un petit peu différent
de ce que vous trouvez sur ce chapitre
analyse airs puisque là dans l'exemple
la variable éducation j'ai transformé la
valeurs manquantes en une variable
données ce qui fait que les manquants
sont pas supprimés alors que ces traités
comme une valeur montante dans la partie
qui est l'exemple qui en ligne et ce
changement-là entraîne un changement
dans la classification in fine et
puisqu'on va pas traiter la la valeur
manquons de la même manière dans las
casas c'est une donnée manquante et donc
du coup on fait les distances en tenir
compte du niveau d'éducation
dans l'autre cas on va tenir ça comme
une modalité donc encore une fois ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que les données
manquantes il n'y a pas de valeur
absolue de règle absolue mais il faut
bien savoir comment est-ce qu'on va les
traiter et voir l'impact que cela peut
avoir sur les résultats alors il ya un
r qui est de savoir où est-ce qu'on peut
représenter les sauts d'inertie de un
indice et non de 1 à moi pour mieux voir
les sauts et bien je vous montre ici que
mon attaque le graphique la gemmi de
1,20 ici je voulais mais de 1 à 10 pour
voir uniquement les endroits qui nous
intéresse on peut on peut facilement
adapter encore une fois tout va dépendre
de comment vous voulez faire si vous
cherchez plutôt avoir une douzaine de
classes
apprenez de 1 à 20 si on cherche
vraiment un nombre réduit on va voir
plus bas
maintenant ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'une fois qu'on a choisi le nombre de
classes qu'on va retenir là par exemple
j'ai décidé d'en prendre trois une fois
que j'ai choisi mon oncle classe comment
est ce que je fais pour récupérer pour
savoir à quel groupe appartient chaque
individu et ça se fait tout simplement
avec la fonction peut être joli donc si
je fais que tu tries je lui passe
un brin et je lui passe
classe donc là jean xxiii j'obtiens un
vecteur qui me dit l'appartenance de
chaque observation à chaque classe et
donc du coup je peux directement dans
mon objet des deux faire des deux
matip au ceccacci à 3 j'ai une nouvelle
variable
alors je peux faire ça à une seule
condition c'est que depuis le début je
n'ai jamais changé l'ordre des
observations dans mes différents objets
parce que du coup l'ordre ayant été
préservé le résultat de catch lui est
bien dans l'ordre du l'objet des deux je
m'explique j'ai pris mon objet d2 les
observations sont triés selon une
certaine dans un certain ordre
et si je fais des erreurs ou des sortes
je vais changer cet endroit là cet
ordre-là été repris dans la matrice de
distance puis repris du coup dans
l'arbre calculer et donc c'est important
de bien de pas voir changer l'ordre si
on veut que quand on fait coach rehab 3
et que je le mets dans une variable
petits pots de l'objet des deux ça que
ça marche bien je vais bien la bonne
catégorie à la bonne observation
je veux aussi sauvegarder la typo de
gower comme ça on pourrait les comparer
d'accord et je vais faire que de free à
-3 donc là haut
faire une typologie en temps j'aurais pu
aussi mettre directement dans l'objet
hdv 2003 puisque l'objet hd mai 2003 qui
aimeraient jeux de données avec toutes
les variables
1 il est dans le même ordre que l'objet
des deux qui était que les variables de
l'analyse factorielle donc peut-être
qu'ici je pourrais sauvegarde est plutôt
en amont dont hdv 2003 mes résultats
depuis que des données telles que un
sous-ensemble des variables qui avait
servi à l'analyse factorielle si je vais
regarder rapidement qu'est ce que
j'obtiens un si je fais un freq de lgv
2003 typo et un de type o gower on voit
obtenu un pardon c'est argaw donc si je
regarde
lefriec deux mâts typo et le frais de la
typo gower on voit
obtient en fait de petits
logis très différentes on est parti de
deux manières différentes de calculer
notre de rendre au g et on obtient des
répartitions bien marquer ici j'ai une
grosse catégorie qui représente 63% des
individus et puis une catégorie un peu
spécifique qui représente 10 % atypique
et une catégorie qui va représenter 28 %
à peu près un tiers de 558 l'âge obtient
trois groupes un peu différent un qui
qui sont plus équilibrés mais ça c'est
lié à la construction de mon arbre
si je reviens si je vous fais plate deux
arbres donc ça c'était le premier arbre
et que je fais un rec tu h clust à a3 et
du coup je mette border et galway des
voix
on a d'abord ce petit groupe un peu
atypique et bien séparé du reste du
groupe
ça c'est vraiment des gens qui doivent
avoir des modalités peu présent dans
l'échantillon et après le reste va se
séparer en deux grandes familles si je
reprends l'autre approche avec bauer
on est sur quelque chose d'assez
différent puisque un peu
du coup les modalités peu présente
finalement pas joué et on va avoir plus
tôt trois grands groupes qui vont qui
vont sortir et ça renvoie une des
questions qui étaient posées tout à
l'heure alors une certaine question je
garde pour la suite pour le pour le flux
mais si on a des modalités très peu
représentées faut-il privilégier
l'analyse de gower et j'ai envie de dire
tout dépend de ce que vous voulez faire
on va regarder l'étape d'après pour nous
qui va être de catégoriser les
catégories que l'on obtient et voir
quelles sont celles ont ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est est ce que vous cherchez à
identifier les atypique auquel cas vous
avez plutôt intérêt à faire une analyse
des correspondances ou est ce que vous
cherchez plutôt à identifier les grands
types mais où les atypiques vous
intéresse pas et voudriez plus tôt qui
viennent pas trop influent et l'analyse
auquel cas vous avez intérêt qu'ils
aient gower gower va être peut
influencer par les individus atypique
donc si ce qui vous intéresse et plutôt
de voir comment les gens la majorité en
fait se structure en deux ou trois
groupes
gower sera peu sensible assez atypique
qui peut avoir un intérêt si au
contraire on veut plutôt isolé les gens
qui sont un peu atypique
on a ré plutôt intérêt à faire une assez
m encore une fois ça va dépendre de
votre questionnement de recherche et on
va avoir les résultats pour voir quel
type o nous intéresse le plus ce qui
nous amène malgré tout à la prochaine
étape
et donc cette prochaine et
c'est d'écrire et les classes obtenus et
c'est probablement l'étape la plus
difficile a tant du point de vue
statistique peu du fait de essayer de
trouver à quoi correspondent ces classes
qu'est ce qu'elles veulent dire alors
une première manière de décrire les
classes c'est d'abord de de les regarder
par rapport aux variables qui ont servi
ravet construire donc du coup ce que
l'on peut faire
je vais faire un tableau donc
hdv 2003 je vais faire un bébé elle se
marie donc pour ça il faudrait que je
mette en mémoire la bridge it is more we
donc si
et hdv 2003 thibert samarie alors je
veux pas toutes les variables moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les variables
conserver à l'analyse est en fait si on
s'en souvient mais elles sont dans des
deux on va exécuter tout depuis le début
on est forcément ça fait un temps de
calcul un peu long avec les graphiques
jusqu'à exécuter tout depuis le début
sauf la partie graphique qui produit
tant de calcul est donc quand on est à
cette étape là dans le script
l'objet
euh si vous
un ga jamais 2003 qu'à toutes les
variables des deux qui a que les
variables qui ont servi au moment de
l'analyse et matip au jeu les
sauvegarder dans hdv 2003 donc si je
regarde l'objet des deux et que je fais
n'est même juste pour voir le nom des
variables qu'il ya dedans y'a que mais
variable de l'analyse donc names d2 ça
me donne le nom des variables de
l'analyse et comme je suis feignants et
que je ne veux pas réécrire groupe âge
sexe est une
je vais faire un tibia il se marie et je
vais faire include égale nîmes d2 mais
il faut aussi matip au donc j'ai rajouté
cnmv deux types au donc je répète n'est
menée 2 ça me donne groupe âge sexe
études pécha cinéma cuisine bricole
sport lecture bd et jeux 19 ans pourra
voir que les noms des colonnes donc
avoir un vecteur de textes si je combine
ça avec la lettre avec la fonction c'est
avec typo j'obtiens le même groupe mais
je rajoute en plus cheap au à la fin et
donc si je fais tibial se marie avec ce
qu'est ce que j'ai fait une bêtise
voilà contrôle entrée j'exécute tout ça
j'obtiens du coup là un tableau des
différentes variables
sauf que ce qui m'intéresse maintenant
c'est pas simplement d'avoir que ces
variables là j'aimerais avoir du coup le
croisement des variables avec typos
donc il faut que je pense à rajouter
d'antibes ils se marient paille égale
typos
un tableau croisé d'accord des
différentes variables croisés que ma
typologie pour information les typos la
typo 1 s'appelle simplement un deux
trois ce que que tchoyi on voit juste un
nom qui dit la classe d'appartenance et
donc du coup c'était à moi de comprendre
ça veut dire quoi la classe une la
classe de la classe 3 et peut-être de
lui trouver un nom plus explicite par
défaut vous avez des pourcentages en
colonnes ce qui m'arrange plutôt bien
parce que je veux pas voir comment un
groupe se répartit entre les trois
classes je veux plutôt voir le profil de
chacune de mes classes donc là j'ai une
première manière de représenter mes
données
j'en fais tout simplement un tableau
croisé qui est quelque chose de
classique en lecture mais on peut avoir
envie d'avoir quelque chose d'un peu
plus visuel pour repérer tout ça c'est
de se faire un tableau croisé mais de
repérer les points de divergence et ça
ça peut se faire avec une représentation
graphique des résidus du chi 2 et faut
s'en souvenir je m'en doute bien quand
on avait abordé un certain nombre de
graphiques by variés on avait vu qu'on
pouvait faire ça grâce à la fonction ggc
bol du package et gally donc on va chat
gg galli en mémoire et donc on va
un graphique sauf qu'avant de faire mon
graphique il ya une petite subtilité
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu mais si je
fais si vous regardez le résultat qu'on
a eu un variable typo ce que m'a renvoyé
coach oui c'est un numéro c'est un
nombre entier
hélas pour le pour la suite je vais
avoir besoin que ce soit bien considéré
comme une variable catégorie elle c'est
une classe et donc du coup je vais juste
transformer si pau en facteurs ont fait
tout simplement avec facteurs hdv 2003
type aux jeunes entrant
en facteurs et je fais pareil pour type
o gower tant qu'on y est car pour g
être important que je précise bien que
c'est une variable à gérer en catégorie
1 on va du coup maintenant appelé
j'étais bon en premier lieu on va passer
le jeu de données
hdv 2003 il faut que j'indique quels
sont les variables que je veux en x et
en y alors là j'en profite et on va
comparer d'ailleurs je veux faire d'une
pierre deux coups comme on dit on va
comparer les deux types ont en même
temps donc on va faire colom x je vais m
typo wadja faire juste hypo puis après
on va voir comment on peut comparer et
en colonnes ce y ce que je veux faut que
je dis qu'une liste de variables que je
veux représenter
et là ce qui nous intéresse du coup
c'est les variables qu'on a utilisées
pour construire donc c'est je peux la
voir uniquement avec nîmes d2 je vais
indiquer deux petites choses additionnel
je vais indiquer celle ce col points
propres
alors pour plus d'informations sur gt
bollain il est toujours un préférable de
regarder l'aide de gt bornes mais plus
précisément le paramètre cells permet
d'indiquer la statistique que vont le
qu'on veut afficher dans les cellules du
graphique et nous on va voir les
pourcentages en colonne cole points
propres pour colonne proportions et on
va colorisées les cellules du tableau
avec les résidus qui deux plus
spécifiquement les résidus standardise
dès qu'ils sont est-il 10 points
résidents je vous fais le graphique
et on parle
et je vais faire un zoom là dessus donc
je
réponse ce que va nous faire donc à
présent ça ne vous fait l'équivalent
d'un tableau croisé en sept tableaux
qu'on avait juste avant vous avez ici
donc en x représenter la variable typos
donc vous avez en haut le nom de la
variable et les modalités une deux trois
donc le son de trois classes vous avez
ensuite la variable groupe d'âge sexe
études pécha cinéma cuisine bricolage
sport et lecture bd qui sont représentés
en ligne et les modalités sont indiquées
côté gauche donc c'est l'équivalent d'un
tableau croisé sous forme de graphiques
l'intérêt c'est que donc là on aa les
pourcentages en nous avons les
pourcentages en colonnes ça permet de
voir comment les choses varient mais ce
qui est surtout intéressant c'est que
j'ai colorisée en fonction des résidus
du chi 2 ceux qui se souviennent pas des
résidus qui 2 c'est quand on fait un
tableau croisé on va comparer les
effectifs observé avec les effectifs
théoriques
c'est le principe même d'un qui 2 et
donc les résidus qui 2 la différence
entre les effectifs théoriques et les
demandes rezé fait qu'il faut observer
et les effectifs théoriques
ces résidus peuvent ensuite être
représentés alors la joie qui manquent
la légende peuvent ensuite être
représentés de manière visuelle or si je
rajoute pour avoir la légende c'est un
jj liu
ici les jeunes de galles si je fais
legends égal 1
donc là en fait vous avez une mise en
couleurs par défaut alors avec les
résidus qui sont qui varient entre ce
qui se passe et que donc les réseaux qui
doit ajuster ils sont normalisées 1 par
rapport à la taille globale du tableau
ce qui est important à retenir c'est que
on considère contre s'il est résilient
deux se situent entre -2 et deux saveurs
on résumer ça veut dire que ce qu'on
observe dans cette cellule ce à peu près
équivalent aux effectifs théoriques
autrement dit la cellule n'est ni sur
représentés ni sous représentés après
certains auteurs artistes qu'on
s'intéresse aux cellules au delà de 2 ou
2 - 2 ou au delà de trois ans de moins 3
pour ça que vous avez les deux ce qui
est à retenir c'est que quand la cellule
va devenir bleu foncé donc on va avoir
des résultats dieu clairement qu'ils
vont s'accentuer vers le bleu ou vert le
rouge
à ce moment là ça veut dire que la halle
s'est il est sur représentée en bleu où
se représenter en rouge donc l'intérêt
de ce graphique là c'est pas tant pour
une publication que pour soi rapidement
repéré ce qui se passe l'un sur la
variable sexe on voit tout de suite
qu'il ya des écarts bien marquer et donc
du coup ça me montrent que dans la
modalité une les hommes sont sur
représentés et les femmes sont sous
représentées et à la verse dans la mode
la classe 3 je vais avoir une sous
représentation des hommes et une sur
représentation des femmes donc un
premier élément pour catégoriser mais
classé de voir ben voilà 3 est une
classe plus féminine la une est une
classe plus
plus masculine si je me souviens de mes
classes je vais refaire un fréquent même
de hdv 2003 typo la classe atypique
c'est la classe 2 d'accord donc je vais
les regarder déjà ma classe numéro 2 si
je regarde mon graphique donc ma classe
2eme classe un peu d' atypique à ce
caractéristiques par quoi tous les gens
dans cette classe à ne lisent pas de bd
d'accord donc les gens alors on voit que
les gens qui lisent les bd sont assez
peu présent un mais deux coups ils sont
plutôt dans la classe hudon classes une
classe où il ya pas de gens qui lisent
de bande dessinée mais c'était déjà
quelque chose d'atypique ce qu'on va
voir c'est surtout c'est qu'il ya 78 %
de gens qui vont cinéma c'est 90% sont
entre 18 et 25 ans donc en fait c'est
une classe de jeunes dont les voiliers
dont le niveau d'étude n'est pas
documenté donc probablement que ce sont
ceux qui font encore leurs études dont
le niveau d'étude atteint n'a pas été
documentés donc c'est grosso modo une
classe de jeunes scolarisés ils ont
moins de 25 ans leur niveau d'études est
pas encore documenté ils vont au cinéma
et ils font peu de bricolage beaucoup de
sport
maëlys pas de bd on a une classe
3 qui la classe un peu intermédiaire on
va avoir qui est sur représentée par les
gens plus de 65 ans donc là on a une
classe de gens plus âgés ou les femmes
sont un peu plus se représenter alors il
n'y a pas pas être étonné c'est qu'on
sait que plus aux ag il ya plus il ya
une mais plus grande mortalité des
hommes donc les femmes sont
surreprésentées aux ag le niveau
d'études primaires est sur représentée
mais on sait que ceux qui ne sont pas
allées au delà du primaire c'est
essentiellement des personnes âgées
c'est et en fait on voit que ils font
tous il pratique touche alors ils
pratiquent tous la pêche ou la chasse
non ils ne pratiquent pas la pêche
chasse pardon excusez moi je lis mal par
contre ils sont surreprésentés ils ne
font ils font peu la cuisine ils vont
quasiment pas au cinéma
ils pratiquent pas la pêche au lâchage
ils font peu d'activité en fait il n'y
pas d'en décider
il faut un se sent pas de sport en fait
c'est une classe de gens qui font peu
d'activité puisque c'est le nom qui
prime à chaque fois qu'ils sont plutôt
âgés dont du coup il ya un peu plus de
famille un peu et ils ont un niveau
d'étude faible et puis enfin vous avez
les grandes masses du cou qui sont bas
qui vont récupérer tous les gens de 45
de 25 à 45 ans et compte du coût des
niveaux d'études plus élevé et documenté
et qu'ils sont plutôt les gens qui vont
faire plus d'activité mais guen on a à
peu près trois classes qui émerge la
classe des personnes âgées niveau
d'étude prix des avec un niveau d'études
primaires la classe des jeunes qui sont
encore scolarisés et la place des actifs
si je regarde maintenant le résultat que
j'obtiens avec bauer est alors en fait
j'ai même rajouter les deux parce qu'on
peut faire ça que j'étais ball m 2
[Musique]
donc pour rappel quand on fait
bauer un gaulois nous a envoyé trois
classes à peu près de même taille
on est sur un rendu qui est un petit peu
différent donc nos classes une deux
trois correspondent pas du tout aux
mêmes arbres que précédemment
ce qu'on peut voir c'est que en termes
d'âge et de sexe
j'ai une classe une qui est
majoritairement des femmes donc la
classe lune c'est une classe plutôt
féminine la classe iii ici est une
classe très masculine à 99% et on a une
classe 2 qui va être mixtes en termes
d'âge on va avoir une classe une qui est
plutôt âgés c'est plus mais c'est pas
aussi marqué que tout à l'heure mais
c'est quand même plutôt des gens âgés ya
peu de jeunes
j'ai une classe 2 qui va être plutôt
jeune et j'ai une classe 3 qui va être
plutôt d'âge intermédiaire en tout cas
ce qui prédomine ici si les 45 65 ans et
probablement qu'on l'a les différences
vont être marqués par le type d'activité
si on regarde alors si on regarde le
niveau d'études
on a une classe
deux qui sont soit les gens éduqués soit
les gens qui sont qui n'ont pas le
niveau d'étude donc c'est à dire qu'ils
sont encore scolarisés
alors que la classe 3 ce sont des gens
de faible niveau d'études et la classe
une est aussi de faible niveau d'étude
en terme de pratique et bien les
chasseurs sont plutôt dans la classe 3
on va
les gens qui m'ont cinéma c'est plutôt
dans la classe 2 les gens qui cuisinent
son saoul il ya alors sont
sous-représentées dans la classe 3 la
classe une va sur représentés la cuisine
et c'est un peu intermédiaire haut
niveau la classe 2 on va avoir du
bricolage qui est très rare dans la
classe une alors qu'on va avoir du
bricolage fréquent en classe 3 et une
classe 2 qui est un peu intermédiaires
ce qui brille comme aussi pas mal au
final
en termes de sport le sport est présent
lui uniquement dans la classe de est peu
présent dans la classe 3 et puis la
lecture de bandes dessinées qui est
aussi quelque chose d'atypique se
retrouve essentiellement dans cette
classe 2e on va avoir des gens qui
lisent de la bd donc là on a une classe
2 qui va plutôt être ont résumé
population jeune ou éduquer ou ce sont
les personnes de niveau d'éducation
plutôt élevés et des et des jeunes mais
on à la fois les jeunes en cours de
rescolarisation et des jeunes actifs non
jusqu'à 45 ans qui va avoir recours
pratique de ce sport va fréquemment
cinéma c'est là on retrouve les gens qui
disent la bd donc activités culturelles
et de sport et puis sur des bricoles un
petit peu il faut un peu de
et font un petit peu de cuisine mais il
plus ni moins que le reste est enfin les
classes une et trois ont plutôt être des
classes de population plus âgée
les plus de 45 ans avec cette fois ci
une claire opposition entre d'un côté
des femmes qui vont surtout cuisiner
mais ne vont pas bricoler et de l'autre
côté des hommes qui cuisinent qui
cuisine peut par contre qu'ils vont
aller chasser et qui vont faire du
bricolage
donc en fait là on n'a pas du tout la
même classification on a vraiment trois
groupes les jeunes et jeunes actifs
plutôt culturels sportifs et les plus
âgés à partir de 45 ans avec la deux
classes qui sont très genres et les
femmes d'un côté qui cuisine et les
hommes qui bricole et qui vont à la
pêche
donc vous voyez
j'obtiens quelque chose de complètement
différent suivant j'utilise la proche de
gower houle approche par l'acm sachant
que là c'est mort a eu tendance ici a
plutôt faire émerger les populations les
plus atypiques et donc du coup j'ai
notamment une classe de petite taille de
10 % qui est un profil vraiment un peu
particulier une classe intermédiaire
d'un tiers et puis une très grande
classe 2 66%
gower va plutôt nous faire des classes
équilibrées
sachant que les atypiques vont passer à
la trappe
on va plutôt regarder plutôt qu'est-ce
qui sur quoi les gens se regroupent en
majorité est ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on
obtient deux classifications
complètement différente dont j'aurais
peut-être pas du tout la même
interprétation sociologique ou social
est en fait je ne peux pas vous dire que
l'une des deux classifications est
meilleur que l'autre
tout dépend de ce qu'on veut voir pour
certaines analyses peut-être que
l'analyse de gower serait bien plus
intéressante alors que dans d'autres cas
de figure on aurait quelque chose de
plus intéressant avec la première est
vraiment suivant ce qu'on fait on n'a
pas les mêmes choses
vous auriez pu aussi faire votre analyse
des correspondances multiples et
lisez du coup une classification de ward
mais war 2 points des c'est à dire sur
la distance de ward simple et non pas
sur la matrice d'existence au carré
pourquoi parce que quand on prenait la
distance au carré alors qui est souvent
recommandée dans lundi ce facteur et
c'est qu'on va encore amplifier cet
effet d atypique qui vont être encore
plus présent alors que si on prend la
distance de ward simple on va moins
amplifier cet effet d atypique et donc
du coup peut-être qu'on aurait quelque
chose d'intermédiaire entre les deux
approches qui convient driller qui
conviendrait mieux
alors ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
dans les classifications on peut en
faire plein du point du stade
la vraie question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que ça permet ou pas de faire
émerger des classes qui font du sens du
point de vue sociologique du sujet qu'on
est en train d'analyser et voir si on a
quelque chose d'intéressant je vous
avouerai dans ma pratique
j'ai souvent fait de la classification
hiérarchique j'ai pas forcément retenu
toutes les classes parfois j'obtiens des
classes qui font vraiment du sens et je
vais les garder pour l'analyse parfois
ça va surtout me mettre en évidence
certaines variables particulière et là
je me dis ah ah oui effectivement il ya
des choses intéressantes mais peut-être
qu'à partir des variables que j'ai
identifié j'ai intérêt à faire une autre
classe cette fois ci raisonnée 1 et qui
va être un petit peu qui va être un peu
similaire mais qui va être pris sur
d'autres critères mail approche
automatisée m'aura permis de mettre en
évidence les variables d'intérêt pour
penser mais classification alors
qui nous est posée ce que la ch peut
être utilisé dans le cadre de l'analyse
des inégalités socio démographiques
ça peut être une manière de l'envisager
si à un moment donné on a plusieurs
indicateurs d'inégalités et qu'on a
plein de choses et qu'on veut essayer de
créer une typologie d'inégalités mais
encore une fois tout dépend de ce qu'on
veut analyser et tout dépend de comment
on interprète la question de l'inégalité
est ce que c'est par rapport à des
variables d'accès à un certain nombre de
droits ou de possession ou est ce que
parce qu'une autre manière de mesurer
les inégalités c'est de partir sur des
indicateurs de revenus par exemple et là
on serait plutôt sur d'autres approches
sur des indicateurs d'inégalités de type
d'indicateur de génie donc il n'y a pas
de réponse unique mais la ch peut être
un des outils à un moment donné la
classification à sentir archi que c'est
quand vous avez plusieurs variables et
que vous voulez récupérer tout ça pour
faire une typologie simple qui va vous
servir après soit comme pour faire une
analyse d'une régulation multi niveaux
pour les facteurs associés à la
typologie soit parce que cette typologie
là pourrait devenir une variable
explicative dans une autre étape de
l'analyse à un niveau ultérieure là je
vous ai présenté les outils la
classification ascendante hiérarchique
avec adieu 4 sachez qu'on peut aussi la
faire avec facto myners par défaut moi
je préfère souvent des roquettes parce
que vous voyez là on a vu toutes les
étapes de la de la classification
hiérarchique avec ou sans la distance de
l'acm facto myners c'est un peu un tout
en un avec une fonction qui s'appelle h
cpc qui en fait tu réalises le calcul de
la matrice des distances à partir du nas
et m
calcul d'un programme et le
partitionnement la population en classe
donc en fait ça fait un petit peu tout
d'un coup mais je préfère pour ma part
plutôt faire les choses étape par étape
pour voir ce qui se joue par des fois je
s'épaissit calcul dont programme à
partir du carré des distances du fis de
avec la méthode de world dont celle
approche que je vous ai raconté tout à
l'heure il ya une partition automatique
qui vous est proposé qui s'appelle
baisse cross country
ce qui est intéressant à voir c'est que
vous allez avoir ce type de résultat
graphique et vous avez une fonction qui
peut être intéressante qui est de
représenter la classe dans le plan
factoriel mais avec votre arbre et qui
du coup est assez intéressant parce que
ça paraît de visualiser l'arbre non pas
sur deux dimensions sur une seule
dimension et sur deux dimensions puisque
l'arbre présenté par rapport au plan
factoriel ce qui est assez intéressant
quand on passe quand vous faites votre
classification hiérarchique
après l'analyse factorielle vous avez
toute façon intérêt à présent on va
regarder le résultat dans le cadre du
plan factoriel parce que c'est une bonne
manière de voir si on on représente les
choses un peu correctement peut-être
pourra vous rajoutez du coup ce dernier
ce dernier graphique donc on l'a vu si
je reviens sur le court sur l'analyse
des correspondances multiples donc la
cemac à 2,4 pour représenter un
graphique des observations ce
affi klein donc les observations selon
un groupe c'est donc avec f vise mca
inde
vous voyez ce que je vais faire je vais
copiez ce code la halle est ici donc
nous assez manga du même nom la typo l
aidant hdv 2003 dollars typo et donc 6
ça là vous voyez je représente le
graphique de l'analyse factorielle et
comme la honte est ce utile typo simple
c'est celle qui construite à partir de
l'analyse factorielle vous voyez la
projection de de la typologie obtenus
dans ce plan factoriel si on est passé
par la distance du fils de et à partir
l'acm ça fait toujours sens de se
représenter ça parce que en général
c'est qu'on a fait aussi en amont de la
classification d'april temps regarder
aussi comment se projeter les variables
dans le plan factoriel et donc du coup
la classification qu'un élément de suite
voilà je vous remercie
on va s'arrêter là pour ce soir donc
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette session
sur la classification ascendante
hiérarchique
on clôture avec cette cession le
deuxième cycle des webinaires dans le
troisième cycle des webinaires pardon
donc la semaine prochaine nous aurons
une session de type faq foire aux
questions
donc je vous renverrai ce sera un lien
zoom penser à préparer en amont les
questions que vous pourriez avoir quoi
qu'il en soit je vous souhaite vraiment
une bonne continuation
quelques informations sur le cycle
suivant alors le rythme risque peut-être
de changer un petit peu je suis pas
certain de rester sur un rythme
hebdomadaire
d'une part parce que les webinaires se
font en plus de mon activité de
recherche principal est de mes
différentes obligations en tant que dans
des comités de rédaction
en tant que responsable dax dans mon
laboratoire ou dans d'autres commissions
jeu peut siéger
du coup et puis j'ai mes projets à gérer
au quotidien et mes étudiants donc du
coup peut-être que le rythme va un petit
peu être réduits on va au minimum être
sur soi soit parfois disons qu'on sera
peut-être pas sur toutes les semaines il
y aura peut-être parfois des semaines de
pause mais au maximum toutes les deux
semaines et
on devrait du coup dont la dans la le
prochain cycle on va aborder analyse de
survie analyse de séquences pour avoir
un peu d'éléments biographiques et après
je pense qu'on va plutôt continuer sur
des exemples concrets donc notamment je
vais revenir sur des exemples analysis
de trajectoire sur des données réelles
c'est un des chapitres analyseur mais
qui je pense nous tiendra au moins trois
ou quatre séances puisque sur un même
jeu de données on pourra aborder de
l'analyse de survie classique de
l'analyse de séquences une régression
logistique multi nominal un modèle
observations répétées un modèle de
souris mutées l'état et abdellah classe
la tante dont vous voyez plaint d'
approche différente donc c'est une
manière en fait d'introduire ces
différentes techniques par un exemple
concret et puis j'essaierai aussi de re
prévoir quelques sessions sur des
exemples de graphiques avancés avec gégé
pelote de où l'idée ça va être de vous
accompagner pas à pas sur un graphique
plus complexe pour mieux comprendre la
logique de ggp lot
et puis jean préparation des choses qui
ne sont pas encore sur l'analyseur et du
coup ça me demande un petit peu de ton
un peu une synthèse sur les différents
types de modèles en quelqu'un a utilisé
un modèle de poisson une régression
logistique
c'est quoi la différence entre un modèle
mixte ou un modèle ge donc sans rentrer
dans tout le détail mathématiques de ses
modèles au moins vous donner des clés
d'entrée là dessus et puis je pense à
l'occasion essayer de faire une session
sur les sur les différents contrastes
dans les modèles et mieux comprendre en
fait qu' on n'est pas toujours obligé
d'avoir une modalité de référence et
qu'on a d'autres manières de modéliser
tout ça dans les modèles donc voilà ça
va arriver dans les prochaines séances
peut-être pas toutes les semaines mais
mais mais voilà en tout cas très bonne
soirée à vous on se retrouve du coup la
semaine prochaine
sur zoom pour pour une session de type
évacués et à très bientôt
voilà merci à vous